[Musique]
c'est comme si son illustre
arrière-grand-père veillait sur lui pour
l'encourager à exprimer des vérités qui
dérangent
tushar gandhi n'hésite pas à dire que
les humains sont responsables de la
pandémie de kobe 19 mobile est double il
est [ __ ]
ils blâment la surconsommation et la
visite et pour la propagation rapide et
la ténacité de lakovic 19
même aujourd'hui selon lui personne ne
veut changer de style de vie
tushar gandhi n'arrive toujours pas à
comprendre que le remède le vaccin soit
devenue une arme politique pour certains
et une occasion d'affaires pour d'autres
even in de ce serait quand même face à
une telle menace à la race humaine
l'opportunisme et l'appât du gain
l'emportent se désole-t-il dandy l'un
des deux ministres
le mahatma gandhi lemaitre de la
non-violence est reconnu pour avoir tenu
tête à l' empire britannique et conduit
l'aide à son indépendance en 1947
la photo a une place de choix dans le
salon de tushar gandhi
le petit garçon en noir et blanc avec le
père de la nation indienne et son père
manie la halle le deuxième des quatre
enfants du mahatma gandhi les gens
attendent beaucoup de moi en raison de
mon nom explique-t-il mais j'en ai soit
un grand nombre on ne peut pas hériter
des qualités de mon arrière grand père
il faut les cultiver le paysage
enrico il croit que si gandhi vivait
encore aujourd'hui c'est ce que touchard
surnomme l'épidémie de haine qui sévit
aux quatre coins du monde des états unis
à la chine en passant par l'inde qu'il
inquiéterait plus que tout et munich
[Musique]
il se désole de voir sur les réseaux
sociaux que les utilisateurs répondent à
la provocation en déversant leur propre
fiel ce qui ne fait qu'ajouter au climat
toxique selon lui even grimaud
même si l'avenir mondial lui semble
sombre tushar gandhi s'inspire de son
arrière grand père pour demeurer
optimiste verrez au principe de
simplicité non-violence tolérance
patience des valeurs qu'il veut propager
à son tour ici philippe leblanc joe cada
bombay